i think the
homeless in general just feel that
they've been completely forgotten by
society that
nobody cares about them nobody cares
if they wake up tomorrow they might even
feel like they
think that people hope that they don't
wake up tomorrow and i didn't think that
anybody should have to feel like that so
i decided that when i became a pa that i
wanted to focus on on the homeless
population
so street medicine is really a program
that was born out of the idea that
everybody matters we see that there are
certain segments of the population
that just don't access health care the
way everybody else does
because allentown is a relatively small
city it is still surrounded by wood so
most of the homeless you're not going to
see
sleeping outside on the street
so they go live in the woods and tents
so that's usually where we have to go to
find our patients
i have a backpack with
over 20 medications we have an ekg
machine we do point-of-care testing
where we can get different blood work
the whole idea is to deliver quality
care on site in a place where the
patient feels comfortable
do you still have that inhaler mike yeah
how often are you using it
102 over 68.
everything we do is completely free we
provide free medications free labs free
diagnostic studies
so they don't need insurance
and we have the same incredible people
that see them all the time they get to
know us and trust us and we're lucky
enough that they allow us to help them
okay just breathe normal
doing this job can be extremely
difficult
you just see things that are
really hard to see and and sometimes
feel helpless
but one of the things that that i always
try to do is
just try and completely forget myself in
it to remember that this is not about me
at all it's just about the patience it
doesn't matter if i'm tired it doesn't
matter if i'm frustrated with trying to
help somebody
it just doesn't matter about me it
matters about them
so i try and focus on them and their
needs
you